Before 1994, addresses was divided into a Network ID
portion and a Host ID portion. So if we
take our 32-bits, suppose the first bit is a
0. Note that, that's half of all IPv4 address
space. Anything that starts with a 0 is going
to be known as a class A address and
the next 7 bits will represent the network ID
or the network that owns this portion of address space.
The remainging portion Of the address space is
dedicated for hosts on that network. In this case,
any class A network can support up to
two to the twenty-fourth posts. Addresses that started with
one zero were designated as class B networks,
where the first 16 bits signified the Network ID
and the remaining 16 bits signified the Host
ID for that network. Note here that each class
B address range represents about one sixty-five thousandth of of
all internet address space. So, discounting the first two bits which indiciate
that this is a class B network, we have about 2 to the 14th, unique class B's.
Each of which can have two to the sixteenth, or 65,000
hosts on each network. Class C's use the first
24 bits for the Net ID and a remaining eight for a Host ID. So each class C
network essentially can only have 255 hosts on it. This plot shows the BGP
routing table size as a function of the year, starting in 1989, and going up to
1994. You can see that at this time,
the internet routing table is quite small. It started,
at less than 5,000 prefixes. By comparison now
we have about 500,000 IP prefixes in the internet
routing table. But we can see in this
period, that internet routing table growth began to accelerate,
in particular the growth rates were exceeding the
advances in hardware and software capabilities. And, in particular,
we began to run out of the class
C address allocation. There were far more networks that
needed just a handful of IP addresses, such
as a class C address space could provide. And
yet because only a certain range of the IP
address space could be used for class C addresses
we began to run out fairly quickly. So there
began to be a need for more flexible allocation.
The solution to this problem is something called classless
interdomain routing, or CIDR. Something that we'll cover in
the next lesson.